how did kilowatt not know nen this young
honorable and very sharp fingernaild
assassin lad is one of the greatest yet
most inconsistent characters in all of
the hunter hunter full disclosure
kilowatt is my personal favorite
character but he's also the one that
tends to melt my mind brain the most
because killer was character proposition
at the start of the series is that he is
physically young but has a wealth of
experience he has a power Sim veteran of
the world however as time goes on kilwa
needs to serve the gone wrong as the
bright-eyed amateur dude guy learning
about the world for the first time and
these two contrasting elements are very
difficult to pull off within a single
character especially when it comes to
nen one of the biggest questions in the
series is exactly how kilowa went
through his whole life up until meeting
Gone without so much as discovering the
concept of nen and the most common
explanation for this which I often
subscribe to is that Togashi didn't plan
the nen system when he started riding
Hunter Hunter which has led to a series
of outright potholes scattered
throughout Hunter Hunter several of
which entwine with kilua such as how he
could have possibly spent two years
visit Heaven's Arena without
encountering a single drop of that um
juicy juicy aura or how does kilua
perform what appeared to be nanabilities
without invoking the nen system and most
egregiously how did kilua recognize
xeno's drag and dive during the Chimera
antarct when he had had no opportunity
to see it beforehand again the easy
answer to all of those is that Togashi
didn't plan n and we will be discussing
the points both for and against that
idea however there is also a competing
hypothesis one which interests me quite
a bit which is that tagashi may have
planned then but he did not plan kilowa
he didn't anticipate the role that
killua would go on to play in the series
and so it has left the character
vulnerable to quite a few narrative
contradictions either way what we have
here is a character who is
simultaneously experienced yet a
complete amateur a character who
understands the world has lived in it
and yet knows nothing about it and a
character who is both seen and
experienced nen on several occasions and
yet still has no idea that the concept
even exists that is the killer problem
and we are going to solve it also this
video is sponsored by raid Shadow
Legends the quintessential AAA Champion
some experience but look what good are
champions without some bosses to use
them on luckily raid is full of super
tough bosses like big old Dragon Super
Hot Fire Knights a very brisk ice Golem
a spider that one there I'm used to
finding that already in Australia and
the Minotaur which is a very very angry
cow man and right now Love Is in the Air
as new players can enjoy a special
Valentine's Day themed adventure with
raid Love quest all you need to get
involved is to download raid copy your
in-game player ID and then head to
raidlovequest.playroom.com to play one
of the Valentine's themed minigames for
a chance to win some fantastic in-game
and real-life prizes including
Valentine's day-themed raid Champions
and even Amazon gift cards worth up to a
thousand dollars and if you're an
existing player you can use this special
promo code to receive a small
Valentine's Day gift from raid to you
plus new players use my link or scan the
QR code right here and get a free
starter pack with this core in game loot
so go do that thing but pronounce back
to you me and going chronologically the
first issue counter is Heaven's Arena
kilowa was abandoned here by silver at
the age of six and told that he couldn't
come home until he reached the 200th
floor which took kilowatt until the age
of eight to do now at face value this
seems fairly reasonable I mean not
abandoning a child of the brutal combat
place but in terms of the general
argument of the video the 200th floor is
where all of the nen users reside in
kilwa never actually stepped onto that
floor he just won the right tube and
then he went home but that is a bit of
an oversimplification because the 200th
floor is just the point where everyone
knows how to use nen and if not then
they are brutally brutally initiated but
that doesn't mean you won't encounter an
end user on flaws 1 through 199 gilowa
himself discovered this during his
second stay at the arena where he fought
against Zushi on the 57th floor with
Zushi using both ten and Bren in his
fight against kilwa to be fair he wasn't
supposed to use renzu she just got a
little bit upset and then move you know
it happens but the point is that it's
not some sort of unspoken rule not to
use nen until you reach the 200th floor
it's just that by that time knowing nen
is is the absolute bare minimum and I
can believe that God and kilowatt didn't
encounter any nen users aside from Zushi
that is on their Journey to the 200th
War because it only took them a week to
get there and very much fast tracked the
entire process however for a much much
more younger a killer it took a whole
two years to reach the 200th floor and
so it's a much bigger ask to believe
that he never fought a nenues although
maybe he didn't he just never realized
bike Zushi kilua may have just thought
in a damn that guy's tough for some
reason but at the same time Heaven's
arena is also at the center of a much
greater than controversy because it does
televise matches featuring high-level
nen users on the 200th floor and even
above with all of the floor Masters and
sure people can't see the actual
abilities being used I mean unless it's
conjuration but magical powers are still
well and truly on display taking Castro
for example people watched him literally
clone himself and kilua would have been
exposed to so so much of that over the
course of two years if not fighting
against it then just having it present
and in your face at all times in the
arena now this isn't a bottle that comes
later the heavens Arena ratio is much
more of an appetizer because it just
requires a much greater suspension of
disbelief than usual to buy also fun
fact when gon and kilwa reached the
200th floor there were not including the
boys
171 fighters on standby all of whom were
combat geared nen users to put that
number into some perspective that is
almost a third of the entire Hunter
Association I mean yes it includes
Fighters like Guido but the hunter
Association isn't all that great either
containing figures like pockel and Barry
yeah there's there's a dude literally
named Barry I'm sure he's powerful but
more accurately he's probably mid at
best as an aura wielder I guess what I'm
trying to say is that if everyone at
Heaven's Arena banded together then they
would have a pretty decent chance of
overthrowing the association and on
another note it really puts into
perspective just how many unregistered
Aura uses there are out there in the
world it's a lot to some family issues
now one common explanation for Killer's
lack of knowledge is that his family
wanted to train him at a later age I
don't think this argument really holds
up because they trained killer and all
sorts of other horrifically brutal ways
and also taught him allegedly superhuman
but non-nand-based abilities plus it
completely falls apart when you consider
carlitor he is the younger zotic sibling
and had a fully fledged ability and the
general Mastery of Aura to be considered
a phantom troop applicant by the time
that he was still somewhere between the
ages of 10 and 11. meanwhile at the same
age kilowa still didn't even know that
Nan existed there is a better zotic
family argument which we will get to in
a bit but first it's really important
that we address killua's abilities
before being able to control Aura kilowa
possessed an arsenal of dark arts the
most iconic of which being the Rhythm
echo which was explained as an
application of Silent Gates resulting in
the creation of after images it's
explained pretty well to be honest and I
100 buy it at the time however if this
sort of thing was introduced post
Heaven's Arena then it would be 100 an
inability and the explanation would be
something like kilowatt either conjures
or emits the after images with part of
the ability cost being to perform the
silent Gates perfectly meanwhile another
one of the kilowatt dark arts are the
transformative claws that he can invoke
at any given time with those funky razor
sharp nails that do all of the
decapitating and again if this was
introduced to post Heaven's Arena then
it would be explained as a nenability it
would be either very obvious enhancement
like what remot did with his feathers or
maybe even conjuration because we have
seen kondra's kind of weirdly contort
and manipulate their bodies so you know
what having mentioned the m word it
could also be manipulation like how
illumi is able to control his body shape
however that would be pretty
inaccessible to kilowatt as it is his
exact opposite Affinity as a transmuter
to bring things back here's the basic
hypothesis ogashi did not plan Nan as a
result a series of characters in Hunter
Hunter with more experienced roles are
brought to life where they baked in set
of powers this includes all of Killer's
superhuman abilities but also stuff like
hisoka's Kant and illamies at that stage
very vague yet scary Powers the
difference between kilowatt and the
latitude is that afternoon was brought
up it could be retroactively applied to
them hisoka and illumi fit very nicely
into the newly established boxes and
because they were mysterious
antagonistic entities they were allowed
the luxury of being considered nen users
all along this is a luxury that kilowatt
did not have his abilities could not fit
into the your system because his
protagonist to character Rock needed him
to be unaware of net which results in
these early inconsistencies that's the
basic one but here is the less basic
hypothesis tagashi did plan then however
killa's character Arc was not planned to
the extent that he was going to become a
student alongside God his role could
have been to introduce gone to or even
teach gone then or not I mean it could
have been a lot of things I don't like
speculating on original intentions too
much because Togashi himself didn't even
know at the time the killer does have a
third Dark Art ability that a lot of
people often forget called The Snake
awakens or serpent work in the viz
translation the skill whereby his arm
seemed to take on these tentacle-like
properties which is eerily similar to
the tentacle-ish technique used by up in
his fight against shoot I'm willing to
write that off as you know a bit of
artistic flair up is of course doing it
literally whilst kilua is invoking out
artistic license for the sake of
atmosphere tentacally atmosphere the
reason why it matters though is because
the snake awakens isn't shown to us
until the Chimera antarct long long long
long after kilowa has actually learned
net however Togashi makes no attempt to
explain it with aura and in fact he
strongly suggests the exact opposite
that this is one of the pre-existing
assassin techniques which significantly
weakens the inconsistency argument
because now Togashi is adding new
non-auribase skills even after nen has
become a fully formed system but it
could also be tagashi recognizing his
early retrospective inconsistencies and
trying to blend these two Power Systems
together in a much nicer neater way
there's also the explanation that
Killer's pre-existing skill set is an
unconscious use of net this is possible
because in chapter 50 Wing explains that
gone has unconsciously learned zetsu and
may have actually been using it
throughout a lot of his life due to
growing up in all of the natures and
stuff although the key difference is
that zetsu is a basic principle of net
whereas kilua's skill set would be a
series of fully realized hatsu so it's a
lot harder to buy that it's an
unconscious manifestation but then again
it's not like he would be the first to
do so chromagi is a great example of
someone who created an inability without
ever knowing what nen was so it could
absolutely happen with killer as well
but the one thing that is incredibly
difficult to reckon with either way is
Dragon dive at the commencement of the
palace Invasion the extermination team
are subject to Xeno zoldx Dragon dive
with the narrator stating something
along the lines of nobody except kilowa
knew what was happening when in fact it
really should have stated nobody
including kilua knew what was happening
because there is no way that he actually
saw the ability before this point
because after learning then kilowatt
didn't encounter his family again until
this point so one explanation is that he
did in fact see it you know see it as a
child but it was all invisible he just
sort of saw the destruction happening
around with the other explanation being
that he heard stories about it as a
child which he still is kilowatt is
still a child I think my wife didn't
forget that both of which aren't amazing
because kilowatt knew exactly what was
happening in less than a second there
was no time to go hey this is similar to
a thing I've heard or hey this is kind
of similar to The Invisible grandfather
ability I saw that one time there was
none of that kilowatt just knew and I
honestly believe that in this moment
tagashi forgot which is fair enough you
know that happens writing stories is
hard but it's a pothole that can only be
filled by the fan base waking up at 5am
every morning to train ever so hard in
order to perform the mental gymnastics
required to explain it now with that
said there is one idea that can
potentially solve the killer problem
whether it was planned or whether it was
more likely accidental by Togashi there
is something that we can latch onto
which is the thought that kilua was
deemed a Problem Child by both Silva and
dylomy they both feared that he would
run away from the family forever if he
was equipped with the power to do so and
as a result they decided to purposely
delay kilwa's nen training in an attempt
to retain control over him this would
explain why Carlito was trained at a
much younger age than killer because
Carlito was deemed you know a good boy
and thus worthy of the auras but it also
ensures that kilwa would not have the
tools required to remove illumi's needle
which he did do in about a year after
learning then and so with the hunter
exam ilami may not necessarily have
needed a license for a job as he stated
and he may have entered to purposely
ensure that kill were failed because if
he passed the exam then he would be
taught then in the secret Final Phase
and to a lesser degree being a licensed
Hunter would give killer the ultimate
physical Freedom he can travel almost
anywhere and earn practically unlimited
monies and you know that got that kind
of ultimate freedom is very
counterproductive if you're trying to
control him plan would have been to mold
killer mentally before giving him access
to the full potential of an end user
although if this was the case Silva
clearly didn't invest in it too much
because during the zeldick arc he just
sort of went yeah whatever and let
killer would go with gone believing that
his son would return one day due to
reasons even so I still think that this
is the best solution to the killer
problem if we really need something to
like latch onto then that's it although
the truth is more likely that there's
nothing wrong with tagashi's writing
style the improvised nature of Hunter
Hunter has made it one of the greatest
fictional works of all time in my
opinion but the lack of planning does
come at a cost here and there with kilwa
forming quite a difficult intersection
of ideas because thinking about it he
has to simultaneously be both gone and
hisoka kilowa has to be the bright-eyed
young boy on a journey of Discovery but
also the grizzled experienced powerful
murder and they do think that Togashi
pulled that balance off better than he
quite frankly had any right to